Okay.
What's going on is bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you.
Oh,
I've just chow.
Happy Turkey day to you.
Oh,
you know,
stuffing and potatoes and pie and beer.
Cranberries and gravy.
And your cousin who's gay?
Um,
hey,
what's going on?
How are you?
Happy thanksgiving.
Happy not having to fucking go to work today.
Huh?
You around the table and just sitting down yet?
Well,
if you haven't gone downstairs yet,
I got,
I got some advice for you.
Today is going to be a day.
I think that's going to be a lot of fucking arguments.
A lot of fucking arguments at the table,
right?
The big fucking election.
Some people wanted the guy with the eyebrows.
Some people wanted the fucking
with the pants suit,
right?
Um,
this is what you got to to see you.
You're already going to have a fight,
right?
There's already going to be your older brother.
Then it's going to be this person.
Then it's going to be another per,
somebody's going to say something,
right?
And you're going to be,
you're going to have a couple of wild fucking turkeys.
He's just standing over there,
you know,
eating a fucking appetizer or two and somebody is going to be getting on your
nerves.
Maybe somebody fucking wife who won't shut the fuck up,
right?
Why the fuck did he marry?
Or maybe maybe it's the husband,
Jesus Christ.
What is she doing with this guy?
All he does is fucking talk about himself.
Something's going to drive you up the fucking wall.
If it's not this,
it's going to be that this is,
this is the phrase,
this is the phrase that's going to save your day.
Okay?
Saved the whole fucking day.
Cause you're not can change anybody's opinion.
Oh,
these fucking jerk off.
Still yelling.
He Hug.
Well,
could you vote for Trump?
what the Fuck About Hillary?
You're not changing.
You're just gonna fucking yell at each other.
So here's the phrase she got to use to get through this fucking day.
All right.
Along with the alcohol or whatever drug you fucking want to use.
Just fair enough.
No.
Hey,
fair enough.
That's all I,
that's all you gotta do.
What'd you say?
Hey,
hey guys,
guys,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
Whatever.
You don't need to see them anymore right now.
If you're younger and you still live there,
that's kind of fucking tough.
Uh,
I don't know what to tell you,
but if you've already moved out of the house,
why are you still arguing with these people?
Why are you still trying to change their fucking minds?
You're not going to change their minds.
All right?
I don't give a fuck.
If you majored in debating it,
just stupid fucking skull in the woods,
whatever the fuck it is.
You did that.
Now you're coming back and now you think you know something and you think that
you fucking siblings want to hear it.
You know what?
They don't the same way.
You don't want to hear the way they fucking eat.
When they had,
they've had a couple,
two,
three,
right?
And all of a sudden the man,
everything just sounds like they're eating fucking mashed potatoes.
You
know,
you started having these murderers fucking thoughts,
you know,
just fair enough.
Hey,
fair enough.
Whenever it,
whenever it was that what you think is that?
Is that how you look at the world?
Hey God bless Ya.
Pass the fucking peas and carrots.
Fair enough.
You know,
and that's all you got to do that eventually the meal's going to be over.
All right,
and you're going to get in your fucking car and you're going to drive away
unless you stay in there for the weekend.
Then you got to go out to the,
I don't know what you got to.
Oh,
but you gotta write,
you gotta get the fuck out of there.
Yeah.
Thanksgiving is a took.
It's such a great day.
There's no pressure to get any gifts eaten a bunch of great food.
All of that is tremendous.
Okay.
Unless,
unless you go into her fucking family's house or his family's house,
that's a weird one because you know you're used to all your family's food and
thanksgiving.
You know how it's supposed to taste that you're going to go somewhere else.
It's going to taste a little bit different.
You know,
this is like a classic standup bit,
like here's how it usually is,
but when you fucking blah,
blah,
it's a whole different story,
right?
Then you just got to suck it up and just be like,
you know,
worst case scenario,
this absolutely fucking sucks,
you know,
in which case,
fair enough.
You know,
you don't know how to cook.
Okay,
you're supposed to cook today.
You know,
it's,
it's like when it's somebody's birthday,
most people can't sing,
but God damn it,
you got to sing the songs.
So they do the best they can.
Happy Birthday,
right?
They do what the fuck they can.
Well,
sometimes she got to take the,
the,
the same fucking theory of a tone deaf person singing happy birthday to you
because they love you.
Right?
You get,
you got to apply that to food,
which is a motherfucker,
which brings it to how do I make it look like I ate the shit when I really
didn't?
Well,
oh Jesus,
I don't know how to do this one.
What you gotta do is you've got to fucking,
uh,
you got to engage in a lot of conversation as you just sort of fucking hitting
the plate with your fork a little bit as if you almost like,
you know that noise people make when they want someone to make a speech.
That annoying fucking thing,
you know?
Oh my God,
nothing fucking makes my damn blood boil.
Like when I'm in the middle of a fucking conversation at some cut starts hitting
the glass with the fork and then for whatever social fucking reason I have to
now shut up,
you know?
Oh my God,
that gets me God.
But not today.
Not Today.
Everybody.
Hey,
fair enough.
somebody sounds,
something's down the fucking street over there with a little,
a little fucking spoon knocking against some glass.
You know,
I guess we all have to start as adults.
We have to shut the fuck up,
right?
Like we're working for this asshole bay.
You know what?
Hey,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
You know,
he just fucking sit there.
Oh,
here we go.
Oh good.
Oh,
here's a cliched what?
I'm thankful for speech.
Oh,
is that what you're thankful for?
I'm thankful for lady.
Every fucking word that comes out of your mouth is one less worry.
It was one word closer to the end of whatever the fuck it is you're saying.
You know,
that's when you know you're the passive aggressive move is when someone's in the
middle of that is you.
You're fucking as some,
it is just kind of pointed.
Somebody pointed some a plate,
you know,
little fucking,
give me that button right there.
They're still Yammer and on,
you know,
you know back in 1983 when we first saw this house,
right?
And you just sit in their butter and your fucking roll.
Oh is this why the fuck are going to go every God damn year from 1983 hey,
you know what?
Fair enough.
Yeah.
I didn't want to wear this sweater.
Right?
He's fucking have these potatoes instant these fucking potatoes it.
Hey,
fair enough.
you didn't,
you didn't have time to fucking cook rail once.
Maybe they ran out of him down the clothes the last fucking time they ever ran
out of potatoes.
They never run out of potatoes and this country,
it's why so many fucking Irish people over here,
right?
Fucking Irish man,
they tapped out on their own country one fucking time and their whole history,
they run out of potatoes and everybody fucking jump ship.
Right?
But not the real Irishman.
The Real Irishmen and real ladies,
they fucking stuck around.
Okay.
I like these cowards that I'll move to fucking New Jersey.
But you know what a fair enough,
you know,
they wanted some potatoes.
This is one of these days people,
you know,
and if you're a younger man,
you got to enjoy the holidays cause cause they're never going to get,
it doesn't get better then,
you know,
cause you don't know any better.
So the food tastes the way the fucking food is supposed to taste in your world.
Right?
Everyone who's supposed to be there is there,
you know?
So when you get older and you start expanding your fucking world and all of a
sudden you know Jesus Christ,
I mean you're sitting there with somebody,
you might even me up me and might be sitting at that fucking table being,
I don't even know if I'm with the right person right now.
What the fuck am I day?
You know what?
Hey,
say what?
Be Fair enough.
I'm with somebody that I probably was never really in love with but didn't
realize what love was.
You know,
and now here I am,
okay.
And all I gotta do is not get in an argument for one fucking day.
I can do this right by Saturday.
I want to be out of this fucking relationship and you know what all I'm going to
be thankful then
you bet your sweet fun.
MMM.
Oh my God.
If it starts going into politics,
if it starts going into politics,
you almost need like a referee during this period of us history to just
literally step in with one of those footlocker,
fucking athlete's foot ref shirts,
blower fucking whistle,
and just send the two people to opposite fucking Lazy Boys.
Let it go.
Let it Aa.
It's all she went home.
She went out saw.
Okay.
She's not coming back.
I don't think she's got a third runner.
All right.
Sit down.
Sit Down Buddy.
Nobody's building a wall today.
Okay.
Just fucking relax.
Maybe it could be the peacemaker.
Who knows who the fuck knows.
Um,
I'm actually very excited.
You wouldn't know it this year for Thanksgiving because I'm back in my house.
The kitchen is done.
Oh my God.
The fucking kitchen is unbelievable.
My lovely wife fucking freaked when she saw she wasn't looking at it.
You know,
she says like,
I just want to say it when it's done.
I want to see it when it's done.
I didn't,
I was peeking at the presence the whole time.
Ruin in my Christmas,
but I will send it makes somebody had to make sure that shit was looking.
All right.
So,
uh,
she got to see it from basically a gutted kitchen to just Bam right there,
Fred or fucking brand new kitchen and uh,
it's absolutely gorgeous.
The people who built it.
You know what?
That's what I'm thankful for.
The people who fucking built it,
man.
It's like a,
I can't believe that that thing is in my house and I get to go in there and make
myself a little Lego [inaudible] this morning with some bacon and all that.
By the way,
I bought that fucking grill top.
I bought that lid fucking griddle thing last night and a knee has pissed at me.
Sort of.
You wait,
I'm going to make our one grand slam breakfast right?
And watch a,
shut the fuck up.
A little bit of fucking Hash Brown some fucking Bacon,
right?
Slight the Bacon over and you cook the fucking eggs and the crease of the Bacon.
Nick.
Nobody can handle it.
I don't know why the fuck we have gone down.
Him Obey all those fucking people down there.
If you want him to talk,
he just make them a grand slam breakfast with the eggs cooked in the grease from
the bacon and just be like,
hey buddy,
not for nothing.
I don't know what people told you,
but this right here,
this is America.
Okay,
well she's got to answer a couple of questions here.
I Dunno what the fuck I'm talking about.
It's early out here.
Give me a fucking break.
All right.
What do you want from me?
Okay,
you don't like the park can say,
guess what?
Fair enough.
I get it.
It's plenty of the podcast and you,
you enjoy good God.
All things.
Comedy,
wonderful podcast network.
Go check our Irish affair skeptic tank.
You know the per Chrysler podcast.
I don't know what the fucking names of Omar.
What am I?
What am I being for?
Fucking encyclopedia podcasting over here.
Um,
yeah,
there's going to be a lot of arguments today and it'll be a victory if I'm,
you know,
if you don't get in,
what maybe it could be that person that keeps everybody out of it is everybody
starts screaming and yelling,
you know,
he's
fucking checks offended,
blah,
blah.
Well,
she's a fucking day,
all that type of shit.
And you can be in the back.
I like
just walk right in the middle of it.
Oh Man.
I want to see a compilation of youtube videos of the political fucking,
I almost said discourse.
That's probably the wrong fucking word.
Do you realize how many fucking words I know that I don't even know what the
fuck they mean.
I just know what words they go with.
You know,
discourse goes with political,
political discourse.
You know,
you used the word or Nate when you were in a theater.
I don't know what it means.
I remember,
you know,
I got a computer I can look at,
Hey,
fair enough.
I can look it up.
Why am I,
I'm going to bore you guys with a shit.
Um,
so when he was,
I'm back in my house and,
uh,
one of the great things about being back in my house is when I get back to my
house.
Okay.
I get back to all my sports packages.
I got to fucking Santa Rice package.
Not Bragging.
I'm thankful for it.
You know,
I have it.
You don't hate.
Fair enough.
Come on over.
All right.
I got the fucking NBA one.
I don't even know what it's called.
I just watched the Celtics.
To me it's a Celtics network.
I'll watch the first half yesterday.
We'd do it all right against the fucking Brooklyn Nets.
You know,
I think it's cool they moved to Brooklyn,
that place when they were in New Jersey.
I was just sad.
It was just a sad fucking place,
you know,
maybe not for the devils,
but for the nets.
It was fucking sad,
you know,
admitted New Jersey people you never had love for him.
You know,
then that's where like that foreign exchange student who never fucking went
home,
you know,
or whatever.
You adopted a kid cause you thought it was a good idea.
You know,
you saw one of these fucking stylists out here doing it.
You're like all,
I will do it.
Fuck it.
We'll take them on.
What did they have a duty?
You had some good years of Jason Kidd.
I'm sorry if I'm fucking knocking this halls around my mouth.
I've had this fucking cough for God damn.
I don't know,
like two fucking weeks,
you know,
cause my,
my,
my wife with the condition she's in,
she's fucking always hot so she's got the Goddamn ac going and it just dries out
my throat.
I've never been someone I fucking hate air conditioning unless it's like 9,000
fucking degrees out then I like it.
Other than that,
I don't like sleeping,
you know,
feeling like I'm camping in my goddamn house.
You know?
I like it.
Like,
you know,
nice fucking,
70 71 degrees.
I need a seven.
That first number's got to be a seven.
Like the price is right.
You know,
let's see that seven,
right?
You start getting into this sixes.
I'll wake up the next day.
I'm stuffy.
I got a fucking my,
my throat's killing me.
I Dunno.
And I'll tell you,
people speaking at killing me,
I've been a,
I'm starting to begin,
uh,
the building of my new hour and obviously having a kid is going to be a whole
new angle for me,
but the kid's not here yet,
so,
uh,
I've just been up on stage just fucking throwing shit against the wall.
And last night I went up,
did like 12 minutes,
nothing from my other act and I just,
Jesus Christ,
you want to talk about just feeling like you have nothing just being punched out
and uh,
I actually have some leftover shit I could have probably done,
but whatever I did all right.
I did it right.
Went down there with a friend of mine just fucking knocking out new shit.
We'll see.
We'll see my specialist coming out in January,
so I'm hoping I have a very inspirational December.
Actually that's not true because I don't really,
I don't have any road gigs until February and uh,
all do.
I have some fucking road gigs were putting together one in fucking Charlotte.
And I know what you'd thinking like,
dude,
you were just fucking there.
I'm going to be doing the club there because,
uh,
the following day I'm going to Duke Carolina.
Oh yeah,
go fuck yourselves.
I'm going to go see coach k at Duke.
Can't fucking wait.
It's going to be fucking crazy.
Absolute legendary,
legendary bucket list.
You know,
I gotta get my college who fucking games going here.
Yeah,
I saw Indiana University,
Indiana Hoosiers,
who by the way,
would they fucking lose to the other day
like Indiana regional technical something or other?
It's their first fucking win of any goddamn ranked team ever.
I really should know the name.
I apologize that I don't,
I saw my adopted college team,
Kansas.
Um,
I don't know if they won their tournament.
I was watching a little bit of that Wisconsin when I watched the,
uh,
the semifinals when Wisconsin beat a Georgetown and I missed the final,
which was Wisconsin versa,
UNC because I went out and I was doing my homework last night and uh,
but I'm a Jay Hawks Fan.
I don't even know why I always wanted to go to their fucking,
the field house,
whatever the fuck they call it.
I,
that's a bucket list thing for me.
I went to an Indiana Hoosier game way back in the day when Bobby Knight was
still there.
The year Michigan State won the,
uh,
one,
the title early two thousands.
I went there and I scalped a student ticket and I was so fucking excited.
Then when I got to the gate,
the guy's looking at me.
I make that point.
I was like fucking in my thirties and shit,
right?
So the guy's looking at me like,
dude,
you're not a student.
And I was,
I had nothing.
I just went,
come on
Nigga.
Sorry.
Kidding.
I remember when that came out of my mouth.
I was like going,
Oh fuck.
I'm not getting in.
Come on.
That's all you had.
You didn't go with,
I'm a graduate student or I got that Brad Pitt disease from that fucking movie
he did with Taraji p Henson.
Remember when he came out as an old baby?
I would tell you this story.
When I watched that movie,
how much I annoyed the woman in front of me.
There's a scene in there when this dude is trying to fuck this chick and the
fucking old baby won't shut the fuck up.
And I forget what he said,
but the look on his face was basically like,
lady,
if you don't get that 80 year old baby,
the fuck out of here.
I swear to,
I can't remember.
I was fucking crying,
laughing,
you know,
typical comedian.
It was supposed to be this really heavy emotional moment that's supposed to
bring tears and instead,
I don't know if you're a comedian,
it just,
it just makes you laugh your ass off.
Cause when I'm,
what am I going to them?
It's fucking sitting there crime and it God damn mall.
I'll cry about that.
I'll cry that I'm in a mall.
I'm not going to fucking cry while in a mall watching a movie right
now.
Maybe I should have.
Maybe that's what the fuck's wrong with me.
But anyways,
um,
so I'll be watching.
I'll be talking about the brewing.
I watched,
I did watch the Bruins versa.
The fuck were we playing?
I know we got Ottawa.
How do you watch a Goddamn game?
He can't remember who the fuck they played.
All I know is Ciara went down in the second period.
Okay.
Well it was one to nothing.
There was one.
Oh,
we played the blues,
my adopted West Western Conference fucking team.
That's right.
It was one of the one then it was to one us than to to them.
Right with Ciara went out.
That's when it started fucking going downhill.
Ended up being four to a nice fucking home loss.
You know,
it was great.
I fucking put it on the center ice package.
They were like a Barilla is at a nice fucking winning streak.
Yeah.
Cause all freckles.
Fucking put it on
and it was,
what the fuck am I talking about here?
I got to,
I got to read a little bit.
There's a lot of advertising,
so I got to break this up this week.
Hey,
bring it up.
Huh?
Break it up.
Alright.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Can anybody tell me how to pronounce this fucking thing?
Oh Shit.
Indo Chino Indochina and a chat.
Oh,
this is this thing.
Read all right.
Ain't no chai is one of the largest made to measure men's brands.
They're making it easy for men to get great fitting,
high quality suits and shirts and an incredible price.
How does it work?
Visit [inaudible] dot com or drop by one of their nine North American show
rooms.
Well,
Geez,
that's pretty exclusive,
Huh?
Nine.
There's 50 states.
Okay.
Pick from hundreds of fabrics and patterns.
Well,
it's just like you're going to see Jimmy the gent.
You got to go pick out a suit down the alley.
Choose your custom customization from a plow lapels to pleats to jacket linings
in more.
Submit your body measurements.
Kickback.
Ah,
fuck that.
Summit
body measurements.
He,
and then he asked for your social security number.
Now they're not like that.
They do that in the United States of America,
not in Indochina.
Um,
kick back,
relax and get ready to step into the best,
most stylish suit you've ever in.
Just four weeks this week.
My listeners can get any premium Indochino suit Indochino for just 389 bucks in,
don't cheat or.com when entering burr at checkout,
get 50% off the regular price for a made to fucking measure premium suit.
Plus the shipping is free.
That's indochino.com Promo Code Burr I,
India,
November Delta,
Oscar,
Charlie Hotel India,
November oscar.com.
It don't shy for any premium suit for just three 89 for free shipping and dope.
China also has amazing holiday deals right now.
Santa Claus is going to get a fucking suit.
Then
they lift up your beard so we can measure your neck.
He old brick,
uh,
holiday deals right now on their shirts and pants and other products too.
You'll never have to worry about badly fitting suits or expensive tricks to
trips to the tailor.
Again,
get ready to look like 1 million bucks or at least 10 grand.
Who wouldn't take 10 grand?
All right.
You wouldn't know.
I haven't had a cigar and fucking weeks.
All right.
Legacy box off the most legendary piece of fucking ass out there.
Legacy box.
Uh,
when was the last time you watched your home movies?
If you're like most Americans,
there's a box in your closet of videotapes,
film reels and photos that don't get watched or taken out.
Worst.
They're actually deteriorating.
Well,
that's scary.
That's good.
Now they got me scared.
Now I want to get this.
Introducing legacy bucks as simple and affordable way to get your recorded
moments digitally preserved on a DVD or a thumb drive.
Can I do a little aside here?
I think I speak for everyone.
When you have that porno you made with your girl that you don't know where it
is,
just make sure you look at this shit before you send it to these fucking people
are legacy box is going to take a whole nother meaning there.
All right,
here's how it works.
Load,
no pun intended.
Legacy box with your ultimate apes film pictures and audio recordings and send
it back.
Uh,
you'll get away.
Oh,
load leg.
I will send the fucking thing back.
You'll get them back in a couple of weeks on DVD or a convenient thumb drive
ready to watch,
share and relive.
This is so perfect.
If nobody knows who the fuck you are,
I can't do this because I'd love to do this with all my old standup tapes,
but I know that they would end up on fucking youtube and I cannot have that.
All right.
Legacy box takes care of everything and provides updates at every step of the
process.
That's why over 250,000 families have used them.
The Huffington Post,
parents magazine,
USA Today and the view are all talking about legacy box.
That's because they're getting paid to.
Even Disney has trusted legacy box to digitize their media.
Oh,
speaking of a company that's got to make sure that they don't send the wrong
porno over there,
those fucking animals,
good Lord,
who knows what they with one of the chorus and for a limited time,
go to legacy box.com/bar to get 40% 40% discount on your order,
on your order,
off your order.
You should say,
that's legacy bought stock comp slash burr legacy box.com/burr with everyone
gathered for the holidays.
Now is the perfect time to share all those old photos,
cassettes,
and home videos.
Go to legacy box.com/burn now to get 40% discount on your legacy box.
Alright,
why is every fucking company so different or difficult to pronounce?
All right,
this is Cecil.
See,
so leave me alone.
All right.
CSO is a place for comedy.
They won't tell you how amazing their but eminently I.
Well,
CSO is amazing.
See that?
You see that?
I just fucking,
I,
I lived up to my commitment.
It's comedy for nerds by comedy nerds.
CSOS spelled s e.
E s o is the new ad free streaming service bringing you hilarious original
series,
handpicked classics,
weeks of Standup specials and more bingeable comedy anytime,
anywhere.
And thethe though they have weeks of standup specials.
They've been in and out of my fucking specials cause I didn't get a fucking dime
from Yukon's every episode of SNL.
Holy Shit.
Ever including new episodes the day after they air the tonight show,
starring Jimmy Fallon,
the late and late night with Seth Meyers,
the day after air,
and they even have classics like 30 rock and recreation or parks and recreation
and saved by the bell.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
This is amazing place.
Even British comedies like the original and the best as far as I'm concerned,
office with Ricky Gervais saw that dangerous guy who does the Emmy's.
He's drinking a beer.
Oh,
what's going to happen?
He's back.
What's he going to do this time?
Probably what he did the first two times.
That's why you keep rehiring him.
Raw hiring,
rehiring.
All right.
The entire Monte Python catalog,
the it crowd and Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge.
Discover the next big,
big names in comedy and watched the icons before they make it big like Louis Ck,
what he had here.
Chelsea Peretti,
Amy fucking shit.
Bo Burnham and so many more.
That's fucking hilarious.
Those last three started like fucking 10 years after me and the talking to them
like they're these old,
grizzled vets.
How fucking old am I?
Critically acclaimed originals and exclusive content like Harmon quests created
by comedian Dan Harmon.
Well,
that's very modest of [inaudible] and funny as hell.
A variety show featuring comedians such as Jim Jefferies and Hannibal Burress.
If you're serious about comedy,
you gotta try CSO stream at any time.
All right,
we get it.
The fuck am I doing here?
See,
so is ad,
you already said that for just three 99 a month.
Right now my listeners can try CSO for free for two months.
When you use the Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout,
can I use it to,
I want to see every fucking episode of SNL,
40 plus years of SNL,
CSOS to place,
but get get it.
We get it.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com right now and sign up for two months with the
Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout.
That's seeso.com
promo code.
[inaudible] all right,
I'll give you a break here for my fucking reading out loud.
Um,
so anyways,
I've been playing drums like a fucking lunatic.
Been playing two hours a day for almost every day.
I missed yesterday because it was the day before fucking thanksgiving.
We had a run around or go get some shit.
Oh,
I didn't mention.
Yeah.
So this year I'm not,
I'm not having,
we're not having Thanksgiving here despite the fact,
you know,
we have a brand new kitchen.
We were planning to fucking have people over.
And then what happened?
Every,
all of a sudden a couple of people dropped out,
everything went out the window,
and then we had to scramble.
Now we've got all this fucking food,
but whatever.
I get the grill top coming.
Oh,
fucking cook it later.
Uh,
we're actually calling an audible and we're going over to some friend's house,
which is perfect,
you know,
because we're traveling the day of.
So most people aren't going to be on the fucking road.
They're already there,
you know?
Okay.
Already get into an argument because they didn't listen to this podcast and they
didn't know enough to be like,
hey man,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
Hey,
is that what you think?
God bless you for thinking that you think that,
and I'm not going to change you from thinking that,
but I don't need to think what you think.
And you know what all I have to do is eat with you today.
That's it.
Then I'm going to walk into the fucking living room,
you know?
Okay.
Well,
I go in there to watch the football game.
Oh fuck.
Are you watching the Westminster dog show instead of the football?
Hey,
hey,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
You'd like to watch a bunch of clean poodles prints and around,
you know,
I don't get it,
but you get it.
You got here first,
whenever,
whenever you got a vagina,
you run things.
Even though you always say you don't.
Okay,
go ahead.
Do it.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Look at that giant float.
Remember?
Bullwinkle of course.
Of course I do.
Um,
anyways,
we're going to a friend's house and all I have to do is just bring the fucking
liquor and I'm,
and I'm good to go near is bringing over a tray of fucking Mac and cheese and
that's it.
And then we're going to go over there.
We're going to eat and have a good fucking time.
I'll fair enough my way through the whole fucking party.
I'll get my God damn car.
I drive home.
No leftovers,
no fucking munch in a way.
Putting out a ton of God damn way,
you know.
Perfect fucking perfect.
Um,
so anyways,
so I've been,
I've been,
uh,
playing drums,
like a fucking loony text,
but yesterday,
you know,
I got all these nieces and nephews and shit.
I got to buy him some fucking toys and uh,
you know,
so I was out there buying,
just,
I don't know a bunch of God Damn Shit and uh,
okay.
I Dunno God,
the fucking people that go in Friday,
you know,
it's too late to tell you guys this,
but you know,
you know,
if you don't have money,
you got to go out on Friday,
right?
You got to get that 40% off that fucking thing.
That's not even going to be there.
And then you get in the store and everything else is regular price,
right?
You got to get out there.
You literally have to risk getting fucking trampled to go get the next Goddamn
game boy,
a flip phone,
whatever the fuck it is your kid wants,
you know,
next year.
Why don't you like,
you know,
there's two ways you can,
there's three ways you can deal black Friday.
Okay?
One,
all right.
Save up some fucking money,
you know,
by some less expensive gifts.
Shoplift,
you know,
shoplift on a day that is in black Friday.
Or maybe you want to do it on black Friday because then he can fuck you got the
cover of everybody getting stampeded.
They're not going to realize,
you know,
you got to Hibachi underneath your fucking,
there you go ladies.
This is what you do.
You buy some fucking maternity wear.
Okay.
And then you put a fucking a bace underneath the,
Oh my God.
You know,
how many months are you?
Holy Shit.
Is that an Audi right with,
that's the handle.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
okay.
So that's one way of doing it.
The second way is if you know you're going to go down there.
All right?
What you gotta do?
You gotta do a lot of squats.
Okay.
And I take a little bit of Jujitsu cause you know,
you know the fights going to the floor.
Okay.
And don't practice on those fucking rubber mats that they have in the dose.
All right?
You want to get on a nice fucking Lindell linoleum floor.
Okay?
So when you skip the hip and you try to fucking turn them over,
like it's going to be a different surface.
Now,
if you've been practicing on a on one,
those AMF mats,
like all of a sudden you're on the floor,
you know it's going to,
you could,
you might,
you know,
you might throw out your hip trying to slide on that thing.
All right?
I would definitely add some weights.
A lot of big girls,
not a big girls show up.
Big Girls show up on fucking black Friday.
All right?
There's a lot of weight there.
So maybe I'd take a little a kito.
I'd learn how to use their fucking,
you know,
all that,
all that physics coming at you,
is that right word?
Whatever the fuck it is.
All that way.
You've just got to have it pass right through.
You like water.
That's what they always say.
Write an Asian culture.
You gotta be like water,
you know?
Oh,
is that what I got to do?
I don't.
They do it.
I can never touch my fucking toes the way you're doing it right now.
I'm not like water.
Okay.
I'm like the cup that holds the fucking water.
So how about that?
Right?
I know water can drown you and I know that water can fucking,
you know,
it takes the form of whatever shape it's poured into,
but would you like to meet a smash this fucking cup over you had?
Yeah,
I didn't think so.
So being a cup.
Okay.
Or a fucking Sausa also.
Okay,
I interrupted.
You know what?
Hey.
Kung Fu master Jetta guy.
Hey,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
I'll become a water.
No,
the fuck I gotta do it.
Are you gonna do?
Huh?
What am I going do called?
Couple of fucking orders of food here.
Say Bend over at the waist.
Gradually stretching my ham.
He says that,
what the fuck I'm supposed to do?
Dude,
it's your fucking world.
Whatever you want me to do here.
Okay.
There's then option and um,
I guess I said there's three options.
You know what the third options could be.
You could just say,
I don't observe the fucking holidays.
You know,
by the way,
shout out to all the Jewish people today.
You know,
they always get left out on Thanksgiving because of their religion.
They don't celebrate it.
You know what I mean?
They just,
they know.
I was trying to say that,
you know,
I said that to me yesterday.
Right.
And uh,
I kind of mind fucked her cause they said it really quick.
St Jewish people did not celebrate thanksgiving.
You know,
obviously it's Christmas,
but you,
you know,
it's the holidays,
if you're not Jewish,
she's like,
you have a vague understanding of everybody else's fucking religion.
Right.
You know,
there's a day,
you know,
there's a couple of Harlem with Jewish people,
there's a couple of day offs we get because of their religion in September.
All right?
Or at least days we don't have to try as hard.
And then there's a day they eat Chinese food,
which is I believe Christmas or is it,
I think it's Christmas,
right?
I don't know what the fuck they do on new years.
Nobody fucking knows.
So if you're not Jewish,
you can throw shit out like that.
So I just throw out to near and like,
uh,
we're in the grocery store and I said,
you know what?
Let's take time to give thanks.
You know,
and pray for all those Jewish people that don't celebrate thanksgiving.
And then she just goes,
that isn't remotely true or something like he was trying to do with math in her
head.
I forget what the fuck she said and I died laughing.
I was like,
you had zero confidence in that right now.
And then she thought about,
she goes,
no,
they'd sense some fights about fucking given thanks.
Everybody celebrates it
except for Isis.
Any terrorist.
Listen,
listening.
Do you guys have a thanksgiving?
What do you guys give?
Thanks for her.
I can't go down that fucking road.
And it's going to be to God damn politically incorrect.
That's something late night at a comedy club you can do,
but not this day and age or all of a sudden.
Then somebody takes this clip and uploads it to fucking drunk soccer
mom@fourintheafternoon.org and all of a sudden fucking shut up.
There's drink your way to menopause lady.
All right.
A and o a Aka ladies,
ladies,
you know,
fair enough,
fair a fuck enough.
All you know,
Dasher and dancer and plants are in fixed and you know,
the capital records building already had their fucking Christmas tree up before
thanksgiving.
I don't know what the fuck they're doing over there.
There's just,
there's something wrong about that.
You know what about Tommy fucking Turkey?
It was weird this year where I was in the grocery store and we were getting our
fucking all this food for this party.
Evidently we're not having no,
um,
for the first time ever,
I actually looked at a package of Turkey necks and I was like,
I'd eat that shit.
You know what I mean?
Decent me.
What do you,
how do you guys study?
You guys prepare your,
your,
uh,
Turkey necks.
Use it for a stew.
Fuck.
All right,
here we go.
Let's read a couple more of these that I'm going to get on the fucking
treadmill.
Fuck today.
You know,
that's another good thing you can do in the morning time,
right?
Get on a fucking treadmill,
knock out a good half hour or whatever,
you know,
just kill the apps that you're going to eat today.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's read the last of these advertisements here.
Oh,
by the way,
thank you for all the well wishes about me and Nia in our impending parenthood.
Uh,
it was very nice to you.
people said a lot of Nice Shit and now that doesn't happen a lot on social
media,
so thank you very much.
All right.
Oh,
here we go.
Everybody.
Oh,
here we fucking go.
It's our old friends were giving thanks to one of my favorite re-advertising
reads of all time.
Right up there with Sherry's berries.
Everybody who is it?
Okay,
Eh,
zip.
We're good.
Ziprecruiter,
are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job at one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
If you find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job to all the top job sites.
And now you can with ziprecruiter.com you can post your job to 100 plus jobs,
job sites,
including social media networks like the Facebook,
like the Twitter,
all with a single click.
Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll until all ZIP
trued
up.
Um,
probably just woke up the neighbors with that one.
file k what?
They're easy to use.
Interface,
no juggling emails or calls to your office.
Do you think isis uses this quickly?
Screen candidates rate them and hire the right person fast.
Does this person look like they'd strap some explosives to themselves?
Know they kind of still got a little bit of Christmas in their eye.
All right,
swipe left.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter
has been used by over 1 million businesses.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on Ziprecruiter,
ZipRecruiter for free by going to ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's ziprecruiter.com/burr.
One more time.
Try It for free at old zip.
[inaudible] dot com slash bro.
Alright.
SEATGEEK everybody
[inaudible] seat Geek does it geek in every seat.
Just like that poor bastard that went to the cubs game a long time ago with his
little fucking cassette tape Walkman,
you know,
and he stood up with another fucking for others,
cubs fans.
But that Goddamn ball had to hit him and then that fucking left fielder had to
fucking pointed back dude.
And everybody forgot about your shortstop and where's that guy now you know that
guy is,
that guy was actually the grizzly man then he got mauled to death in Alaska.
Thanks to you cub fans.
So I hope you enjoyed your fucking world series parade.
All right?
Okay.
Seek everybody,
everybody.
Everything about Siki is designed to make life easier for sports fans and music
fans.
Seek does all the price comparisons for you by searching multiple tickets sites
and ensuring that you get the best possible deal.
See,
Keke does all the work.
You just sit back,
relax,
and have a fucking Turkey neck,
and you save time and money and seek,
wants to help you get the most bang for your buck.
That's why every ticket on seat geek is given a grade value upgrade based on
value.
Okay?
You'll immediately see any underpriced seats.
It'd be able to find the best deals that fit your budget.
Best of all my listeners get $20 a $20 rebate off their first SeatGeek purchase.
I want to see Mac Davis Bay the bay,
but don't give up on me.
Um,
call to action.
Must read.
Fuck you.
It's going to read it anyways.
Stop.
Tell me what the fuck to do.
You can't put it in capital letters.
What are you yelling at me?
Okay.
See kicks run by the fucking bullies,
right?
Sit down and you're fucking Gig.
All right.
To get your $20 off rebate on tickets,
download the SeatGeek APP.
Go to the settings tab.
Ah,
I fucking hate settings and click add a promo code.
Enter Promo code burst seek was send you $20 off after you've made your first
ticket purchase.
Download the seat Geek App and enter Promo curb cold bar today.
It's the worst thing an old guy like me can hear is I'm talking to somebody
younger and they just go,
okay,
go into your settings.
It's like,
Oh fuck you go into the bowels of this device and just start scrolling and then
click on this and then another window opens up and then scroll down to this and
then do this and then
do that.
And then in the end they're like,
okay,
did that change anything?
Uh,
now,
now at 10.
Oh,
that's odd.
Okay,
let's try this.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Are we troubleshooting right now?
Am I talking to somebody in the Malaysian islands trying to troubleshoot my
fucking phone?
I swear to God,
half of this shit.
I just want to fucking mail it back.
I'm telling you,
man,
we should've just quit.
And like 1995 1995 we had all the technology we need.
All right.
Cars had reared spoilers.
You know,
you had a VCR.
VCR was great.
BCI was great when you didn't know what DVD was when there was no youtube,
right.
People paid for port.
It was a different time.
It really was.
You know,
that's what these fucking millennials are going to be nostalgic about.
Like lesser technology.
I have no idea.
I should talk,
you know,
I don't fucking know.
You know,
you know what I've been looking at lately is because they've got the little one
coming and I want to fucking keep playing drums in the house.
So I was thinking about getting electronic drum kit,
you know,
boil boy would share.
Great.
If somebody hooked me up with electronic drum kit that I could promote for free
on my podcast,
look at me working it.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
I'm going to buy it.
I'm gonna buy it because if it sucks,
I'm going to tell you if it's sucks and on.
So I was looking at all these fucking,
um,
electronic drum kits and for my money,
Roland makes the best ones.
They've always been ahead of everybody else.
So they got it.
This fucking new one that actually comes with a 22 inch bass drum that looks
like a real acoustic drum.
I don't know what the fuck's going on with it.
And I'm like,
holy fucking shit.
Look at that thing.
That's the one right there.
Put your headphones on.
All the wife hears is the sound of the sticks hitting the pads in on that.
That's fucking it right there.
They want fucking 12 grand for this thing.
Okay.
12 fucking grant.
Fuck that.
I'm going to wait like five years by that thing on Ebay for like 600 bucks.
MMM.
But anyways,
the thing I don't like about those electronic kits though is you sound way
better than you really are.
And then your ego starts going through the roof and you're just like,
how am I not in a band that already fucking made it?
And we all have Grammy's and gold records on the fucking wall.
And then one day,
much to his Chagrin,
you then go and you sit behind a real kid and you actually have to produce the
fucking sound
and you're like,
oh yeah,
that's right.
I'm going to stand up.
Comedian.
I almost forgot because I've been playing electronic kit for so fucking long.
Um,
however though I did see a demonstration of the one,
it's the TD cake.
Td.
Something rather 50,
and then the,
with the 22 inch kick and this is how crazy technology is as I just bitched
about it.
They said it was,
you know,
it was good enough in 1995 when they didn't even have the mesh heads on the
fucking kits,
it was like hitting a God damn fucking brick.
Um,
and you took all the fucking,
the whole rebounded,
the fucking stick,
not rebound,
the whole fucking shock of the stick hit and then you took a right and your
forum.
Um,
anyways this guy hits the fucking ride symbol.
This is how incredible the technology is.
And he just takes the tip of his finger like you would on a real symbol and he
just touched it and it's,
the vibration gradually went away just like it would on a real one.
I don't know how the fuck they did that.
He did it all over this symbol too.
Cause it used to be like certain areas you had to hit the symbol and that would
give you the bell sound or a cow bell sound or you could choke it.
But only if you had it there.
Now you can just it all over the symbol.
It's fucking amazing.
But 12 grand.
What the fuck?
Who is that for?
I'll tell you is going to buy one of those fucking things.
One of those Saudi Arabian fucking uh,
oil kids that,
that fucking load up that be 52 bomber and fly all their fucking supercars to
Britain for two months.
That's what you gotta do it fences.
Any oil kids listen to me right now.
You got to buy that $12,000 Roland Kit,
right?
And you've got to have the same fucked up mirrored finish that you got on your
12 Lamborghinis,
you know,
had gold fucking finish.
That's,
that's so fucking fascinating to me.
You know what I mean?
That level of godliness,
like,
you know,
you want like an egg,
you,
it runs the whole gamut when you go around the fucking world is some people like
when you go to Paris,
it's everything's fucking muted and then Bam,
the scar for the fucking hat,
the bag or the shoes,
but everything else is the background singer,
right?
And whatever that big fucking thing is.
That's the fucking diva,
the Diana Ross of your fucking outfit,
right?
And then you go to other areas,
you go to fucking Italy,
some places in the Middle East,
uh,
Armenians,
right?
They're like,
fuck that.
What if we put a group together and everybody,
he got Diana Ross,
you got to rethink all Davis.
They go all fucking diva.
It's a whole other fucking style and the level of confidence.
You have to have to pull that off.
I'll tell you right now,
you know,
can't pull that off.
You have to have a certain level of pigment in your skin to really pull off
flashy shit.
If you notice that shit,
the paste year,
you get to get up to my fucking ancestors.
You know what I mean?
The,
the,
the colors,
it gets real fucking limited.
Forget about when you were a fucking ginger.
I mean the amount that,
the fact that I actually have a red wind screen on my fucking,
like if there was a picture of me right now in my pajamas,
what's,
what's left of my red hair?
You guys watching me talking into a mic with a red fucking windscreen.
Most of you would never listen to this podcast again.
You know what I mean?
But if I actually had some pigment,
you know I can be sitting here with gold frame glasses with a gold tooth and a
gold microphone and you'd be like,
that guy is the shit.
So there you can.
You know what?
Hey,
fair enough.
Fair enough.
You can pull it off.
I can't.
Alright,
that's the podcast for this week.
Hey,
happy Thanksgiving everybody.
And I'm thankful the each in every one of you that you listen to my dumb ass
every fucking Monday and Thursday.
All right?
Now don't get any to into any arguments.
You don't want to be that fucking person.
All right?
Just sit back and enjoy everybody else yelling over politics,
you know,
and then you can just be the cut in the background.
What about Joe by
Michael Dukakis,
Grover Cleveland,
whatever the fuck you want to yell at them.
All right,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a nice weekend.
You can't enjoy your God damn Turkey and egg fair enough.
Don't get near the arguments.
All right.
Oh,
maybe a dope and uh,
let me know how fair enough worked out.
How long were you able,
how many drinks in,
we were able to stick with it before you finally lost your Shin.
I want to hear about the arguments.
All right.
Send them in.
Okay.
Fuck you.
I'll see you.
I hope our
paths cross this time
on
thousand
the,
you can see what I can,
when I
throw my phase two,
the phase.
So the next minute ago,
the county
Thanksgiving Day special Billy Kraka,
there's a new one,
Betty Crocker.
I liked it and I like to cook.
That's a good one.
Love your intensity when it comes to bringing something to the table on
Thanksgiving.
Absolutely.
No Pun intended.
It's,
it's really a no brainer.
Get good at making something and get to a point where your automatic,
oh,
he's talking about,
yeah,
like I was talking about a few weeks ago.
When thanksgiving comes around,
you got to have that dish that you just fucking can make and you throw down and
you take it to another level.
All right?
Everybody else should be doing the same thing.
And then the end,
that's the Thanksgiving meal.
Um,
so this guy goes,
yeah,
you should get a dish downs where your automatic,
how hard can it be?
A you'll,
you'll never been x.
You'll never been.
You've never been expected to step out of your skillset.
If you're baking breads,
no one will ever expect you to bring the cranberry sauce.
Uh,
what should go to this year?
What's Nias specialty?
What's my Goto this year?
How about the whole fucking meal?
Dude,
I'll tell you right now.
You guys stick.
I'm a fuck at one trick pony.
I can make you a Turkey dinner.
Was stuffing
mashed potatoes.
My gravy game is getting better.
I've got to work on my gravy game and I know that's crucial.
All right?
But my fucking ah,
my mashed potatoes,
not a fucking lumping them all right enough body to make you slide off the
chair.
Um,
as they say in New Orleans,
that's Ben woolens accent.
I admitted my stuffing.
Go Fuck Yourself.
All right,
dude,
you don't understand the recipes that I have access to all of my recipes start
with melt a stick of butter and a third,
a cup of Crisco in a pan.
Okay.
So you know it's delicious.
Um,
yeah,
my stuffing.
MMM.
I don't my mashed potatoes or the shit,
but knee is African American,
so she likes more sweet potato.
So I don't,
I don't think they,
uh,
that side respects mashed potatoes the way they should.
Okay.
I feel like my potato,
my,
my United colors of Benetton,
whatever the fuck it is.
Respect for,
for sweet potatoes and mashed potatoes.
I think I'm a little more mature
than the lovely Nia.
Um,
what's Nia specialty?
Uh,
Nias she's just great at everything.
She's one of those people that I,
I'll be out in the kitchen like what the fuck
she be like,
what is nothing to eat?
And she comes out there and next thing he knows he's got a couple of things on
her arms and I dunno,
I'm eating spaghetti or I don't know what the fuck.
I mean she somehow just throws it all together or make some ridiculous omelet.
MMM.
She's actually a true cook.
I'm a little more robotic.
MMM.
I think I'm going to become a,
a great cook or a better cook the way I became a better comedian where at first
I was a joke writer and I was trapped in my act and then I learned how to Improv
and she's Kinda just watching her.
She kind of,
as she cooks,
she's tasting it and doing all that type of stuff where I just,
they said to leave it in 15 minutes,
it's been 15 minutes and I take it out.
Um,
yeah.
Pies.
Okay.
I kind of got the whole thing do from start to finish.
My,
uh,
my appetizer game is terrible.
In fact,
I don't even know if I know how to make one.
I have no idea.
But dude,
I can make a pie from fucking scratch.
Okay.
I can look at you and tell you what all your fucking problems are as I'm making
the pie crust and not even look down once I can just feel the texture.
You know what I'm saying?
That's how many fucking Pi's I've made.
All right.
And I'll take debt pie someday and I'll bring it to your fucking house.
And I'll take a whole hunk of it just in,
I'll just shove it,
write down your throat and these nothing that you're going to be able to say
other than thank you for that experience.
All right.
As of shaking up the can of whipped cream to give you a facial
[inaudible]
oh,
this is the Monday morning.
My voice when I said that
right by voice went up.
If you have to say I am excited.
Why am I excited?
Um,
I don't know.
I don't know why.
Maybe because it's Thanksgiving week and it's a week.
Could give back,
you know,
once a year everybody has to sit down and just really think about why they're so
lucky.
I just shut the fuck up and give me some God damn Turkey.
Okay.
Dead part of the fucking Thanksgiving world.
Since then,
we've got to give me a speech like I like,
I don't appreciate what I got,
you know,
just shut up.
Um,
yeah.
So it's thanksgiving,
it's Thanksgiving Week and day to day,
week to give thanks.
I am thankful.
I'm just fucking around and um,
I'm making a Turkey and a with some stuffing and I had the most insane recipe
for stuffing that none of you will be getting during this podcast because it's a
secret family recipe.
Okay.
So you have to be part of my family or be banging me and catch me at a moment of
weakness.
We have to be a great thing of a girl did that you just lay on your back.
She's riding you and then somehow she,
she's so,
she's so good in bed.
She gets you to give away a secret family recipe.
You're like
27 pieces of white bread.
What holds it together?
It's the egg.
Um,
all right.
I'm literally sitting in my fucking car and my,
my Toyota Prius and a in a parking lot outside.
Um,
my,
my little offices that I have out here,
my little production offices is like inch my way along in my little unerring
pilot I'm getting ready to shoot a non [inaudible] pilot,
which basically means you shoot it and then they look at it and they go either
we like it and then we want to reshoot it or they go,
yeah,
that's why a wasn't area cause that's sucks.
So um,
yeah that's what I got going on in my fucking life.
This creepy guy,
this guy,
this guy just pulled up next to me and I'm really worried that he's going to
fucking,
I put up my windows that he's going to fucking bump his door and then my car,
which he didn't and he's kind of,
Oh I wouldn't say he's really fat.
Definitely has a foreman grill.
Yeah.
That's my fucking love handle.
Just hit my side view mirror.
All right.
Oh you know a lot of people last week broke my balls
and an email kind of way going in like,
you know,
cause thought that guy rear ended me and then go,
what did you get out?
Check.
You know,
what are you the most trusting guy in la?
You don't fuck,
I got a bunch of shit like that and it's,
and it's basically,
cause I figured out what it was told you.
My fucking car happened today.
It was all on electric and then the car kicks over and for some reason it,
it gives you a little push.
It,
it makes the car lurched forward.
I really not selling hybrids on these please fucking podcast because I'm making
him sound like they suck.
They're actually there raw the damn book cars.
But anyways,
um,
it has tweak affects given I like the fuck I'm talking about it.
My fingers smell like an orange because I just ate one.
Um,
yes,
it's the Monday morning podcast.
I do one of these once a week every Monday to give people something to laugh
about as they sit in their cubicles as a drive or fucking run on a treadmill.
And if you have any questions that you want me to answer,
just email me at bill at bill [inaudible] dot com or my space.
Me and uh,
yeah.
Do you have any questions?
I don't care how ridiculous it is.
I will answer the question like this.
Here's a,
here's a,
here's a nice question.
A question number one.
Um,
hey bill,
I've been a huge fan of yours since you barely,
since you were barely beaten by Ruben,
started on American idol.
Have you ever thought about giving it another shot?
Um,
you know what?
My time on American idol,
I don't regret any of it.
I had,
I had a great time.
You know,
some of the numbers that they had is perform like Muskrat love and tie a yellow
ribbon that I,
you know,
I wouldn't trade that for the world,
but you know,
I've moved on and I feel so much,
you know,
I got my sexuality is out there.
If it did I dream that is,
it wasn't on the cover of people magazine fucker standing.
It looked like clay Aiken is what he's basically saying.
And the sad thing is that's not the first time I've heard it.
Okay.
Um,
you know what you did,
you just expose yourself.
We're actually watching that fucking show.
What do you think about that?
Huh?
I don't need this shit.
You know,
people supposed to ask me questions.
He not supposed to make me feel bad about myself.
Like,
Hey,
you look like the gay guy who lost.
We said,
could have been it looked like a gay guy.
One,
you know,
oh,
we see something wrong with me and Jay,
you're sucking Dick.
No,
I'm kidding.
Um,
but they do that.
They definitely do that.
You know what I learned from some of my gay friends that a lot of them actually
don't engage in anal.
They just like,
now it hurts.
I'm like,
so what do you do when evidently they just sort of sit around blowing each
other?
Yeah.
So
let's get to question number two.
Let me see.
Maybe this one will be a little nicer bill,
in my opinion,
all negative bitter people all,
wait a minute,
I'm such a moron.
I came to read here.
Fill in my opinion,
all negative bitter people think everybody,
everybody are always out to fuck them.
Maybe why you have such a handle on conspiracy theory.
Am I wrong?
It's another guy kind of shitting on me.
You know,
for Thanksgiving week,
you know,
you'd think there'd be some more thankful fucking questions.
How do you ask a thankful question?
I just can't ha,
how did you become such a great person is got a thankful question.
First of all,
if you're going to trash me,
can you try to actually work out the grammar so you don't look like a moron?
In my opinion?
All negative bitter people think everybody are always out to get to fuck them.
All right.
In my opinion,
people who don't use capitals or punctuation or fucking morons.
Um,
all right,
let me reread this so it actually makes sense.
Okay.
And this guy's opinion,
of course you have to let me know.
This is opinion in case I thought he had a staff of writers who write his
fucking emails.
Okay?
All negative bitter people think about,
think everybody is what does this all negative,
bitter people think.
Everybody
know he gives you,
you got this thing so fucked up.
I can't even read it right here.
Oh,
negative,
bitter people think everybody.
Everybody's out to get them out to fuck them.
How about that?
Does that make sense?
Maybe that's why you have such a handle on conspiracy theory.
Am I wrong?
Ah,
yes.
Yes you are wrong.
Um,
I'm not a bitter person.
I'm definitely a,
I definitely negative,
but I don't think people are up to fuck me.
Like I don't walk into a bakery and go,
can I get a cupcake?
And when they forget to give me a Napkin,
I don't go.
You see,
I knew it man.
Um,
and I think conspiracy theory gets a bad rep.
Conspiracy theory gets trashed constantly by people who never look into
conspiracy theory.
You know what I mean?
All they do is they see one guy on the news who goes,
is a guy living in the moon and they're like,
that's right there.
That's conspiracy theory.
That's what they,
that's what they all say.
Cause they're,
they all have conspiracy theories like that.
You know,
I don't,
I mean,
I guess,
I dunno.
I Dunno what to do for you.
You'd have to look at some of the conspiracies that I'm into and then make your
judgment from there if you think,
I don't know,
I can't judge myself.
But I mean,
if you read about the Federal Reserve,
if you have a sit down and do the math on your mortgage and realize that the
bank turns you into an indentured servant for fucking 30 years,
you know,
do you ever think about that shit?
Do the math on your mortgage?
I have a $350,000 fucking loan.
If I take 30 years to pay it back,
I paid,
I give them $766,000 plus the 80 grand I put down on it.
So now what are we up to?
$840,000 so at the end of my mortgage,
I'm going to be one of those morons go,
yeah,
no,
they fucking place doubled in value.
I paid three 50 now you didn't stupid.
You paid eight 50 you basically made about 800 bucks in 30 years and now you're
68 what are you going to do?
Take up water skiing?
It's over.
It's fucking over.
You know?
And at that point they've devalued the dollar because they keep printing it with
no gold behind it,
which causes inflation.
Now you can't afford the property tax,
so you have to sell it and you move out and they get another 35 year old to move
in.
Ben Dover,
drop his pants and it gets fucked in the ass.
But 30 years and uh,
yes,
I think that that is a,
I think that that's bullshit,
you know?
Does that mean I'm fucking nuts?
I probably coming off is nuts.
I Dunno.
I'm just saying,
I think my by conspiracy theories are thought out like I feel whatever they're
doing to dogs,
they're going to be doing to us in 10 years.
All right.
And I don't know if you've looked around,
but dogs are basically neutered with microchips in shelters waiting to be
rescued.
That's what a fucking dog is.
Now,
when you were kids,
remember the freedom dogs used to have,
I mean,
seeing two dogs fucking in public was a part of people's childhood and now you
know,
they can't,
they can't even fuck anymore because they've been neutered.
And that's what I think they got to do with us.
Michael chips,
you're gonna deal with the population they're going to get.
They're going to start fixing people
I was on right wing radio.
I'd be like,
I'm,
that's exactly what they need.
Um,
that made no sense and I apologize.
All right.
Question number two,
Bill.
Uh,
are you worried about becoming too famous?
Well,
if 40 years of age,
I'm worried about not becoming famous because I've invested a lot of time into
this.
I actually have a cool level of notoriety.
Um,
I know what you mean.
I think those people who are two famous,
I think they seek it out.
I really don't think the Paparazzi is like the CIA and they have the ability to
figure out when you're going to go to Starbucks without your panties on.
I think there's,
there's a little fucking surf and turf action going on there.
You know,
there's a little bit of the artists playing up,
you know,
don't they call their publicist?
You know what I mean?
I mean,
I,
I couldn't fucking,
I mean,
I don't know.
It's just,
there's just too many famous fucking people.
There's too many places where you can go.
Like,
how do they know you're coming from getting off the airplane?
At the airport.
You've ever seen that?
What happens?
This,
the guy at the sky cap just happened to know somebody in the Paparazzi.
There's somebody nodding right now as if they know and as if they've done it.
Maybe.
Maybe that happens.
Maybe that happens a little bit,
but you know what I mean?
All I know is I look at a guy like Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez and five years
ago when they were dating each other,
j Lo,
what do they call it?
Ben Flow.
Uh,
j lack,
what the fuck did they cut?
Benefit.
Benefit,
right?
Remember that you could not get away from it.
And they were everywhere.
And I was like,
either they have to kill themselves or I do because this can't continue to
happen.
Right?
And then they broke up with each other and then all of a sudden nobody gives a
shit about them anymore.
It's like,
I get when to famous people date that Paparazzi swarm all over you.
But both of them broke up and then married other famous people.
He married a Jennifer Garner and she married a that,
that creepy looking guy.
Who's it?
Julio Iglesias,
she married.
It's like he looks like the Lion Tamer.
It's not the blonde haired one.
The uh,
who's,
oh,
the lion tamer.
Siskel and Ebert.
Who else?
Guys?
He looks like they want to get grabbed by the throat.
Yeah,
Chris Catan looking one.
Chris Catan,
you know,
if they ever do the fucking,
uh,
Siegfried and Roy story,
Chris Catana has to play Roy and that's also,
that's a media partner.
Maybe the blond guy is the media part because he gets to cry at his hospital
bed.
Like Fonz are rally when Richie Cunningham wiped out on his motorcycle.
Remember that?
Cause if you,
I do these fucking leather jacket was going in and out because Henry Micro who's
crying.
Um,
okay.
Let me get back to the question.
Are you worried about becoming too famous?
Yeah,
I,
yeah,
there's a certain level you don't want to go beyond,
you know what I mean?
Like those guys,
like whenever I see like celebrity houses,
they're like,
and he has his own tennis culottes his own fucking movie theater.
And people were like,
oh my God,
that's awesome.
And it's like they never really think that he has his own tennis court and his
own movie theater because he kind of has to because he can't go.
He can't,
he can't go anywhere.
So yeah,
I wouldn't want to get to that level of fan.
I would like Steve Buscemi fame time you saw him and ogs magazine,
US magazine.
I was just thinking,
I all those horrors always wear uggs.
US magazine was the last time you saw him in US magazine is going to get some
coffee.
No one gives a shit what he's doing.
I think you're really control it.
I think your publicist,
you know,
I think as long as you're not brought up on a murder charge or ah,
you're not drinking and drugging and just making a spectacle of yourself.
Yeah.
I don't,
they think of all the famous fucking people out there who just kind of just live
their life.
You know what I mean?
I never seen,
you know,
Anthony Hopkins nuts sack as he stepped out of Alexis.
You know what I mean?
You just,
the guy wears underwear and he's not doing drugs.
I mean that's basically it.
That's how you stay out of the papers.
Just don't do.
Interesting.
Thanks.
Well,
I guess that would suck up,
but you're famous so you get an a level pussy.
That's all a trade off.
All right.
Um,
let's get over to overrated,
underrated.
And for those of you who are new to my podcast,
because I just keep getting new listeners every week we do this one part of
where people send me in their list of shit that they think is overhead,
overhead,
overrated and shit that is underrated and their reasons why.
And I actually,
I'm contributing this week rather than letting my listeners do all the work.
Um,
I would say,
uh,
overrated,
the l shaped couch.
I'm actually right now trying to buy some furniture and uh,
I've had an l shaped couch before and I didn't realize they suck.
Basically they suck because there's no place to put the TV.
When you have people on an l shaped couch because you got people,
they're like,
eh,
they're not perpendicular,
perpendicular to the sight lines are perpendicular.
So why the fuck do you put it?
Somebody has got to turn their neck and the next going to end up hurting.
And not to mention it's a very,
you know,
as people start drinking,
people sightlines start crossing and that's why that's how guys get in a fight.
You know,
you stare in another guy too long,
you think somebody is looking at you,
at least that's what the fuck and Jack Daniels is telling you,
you know.
And next thing you know,
you fucking crash land on the,
on your Ikea coffee table.
It's,
you know where it is.
The guy you end up getting to a fight with.
It's the guy that your friend brings that you don't even fucking know one.
And he and he could sense,
cause he doesn't know anybody,
he sits as far away from everybody as possible and thinking that that's the uh,
the submissive thing to do.
But it's actually an Alpha male move because now he's looking across everybody's
lines sightlines who have faced forward.
So discovery channel thing.
So fuck l shaped couches,
what you want as a couch and then you want,
you want another one of those other couches,
the king with the uh,
with the thing that you put your big square thing that you put your feet on.
That's what the fuck you want.
You don't want it.
You don't want a lazy boy.
You the lazy boys are also overrated.
They're not comfortable.
They're not,
they suck.
And all those airplanes now that have lazy boy FirstClass each and like,
Oh wow,
yeah,
that would be great.
He could sleep the whole flight just,
you know,
one night go downstairs to your recliner and spend fucking eight hours in that
thing and let me know how comfortable then it's
alright.
Underrated,
underrated.
You know what,
I actually,
when I've got some fast food for a bunch of people the other night and somebody
actually took the time,
you know,
on the fast flu foods,
so to live,
they actually push down the tab to let me know which one was cola,
which one was diet and who,
you know,
who had other,
and for some reason it's such a nice thing for someone to do and nobody does it.
So fast.
Food technicians who actually take the time to push that fucking thing down is,
uh,
is really underrated and I think they deserve a race.
Um,
all right,
those are mine for fuck for the weaker.
Right.
And here's some more peoples overrated friends.
The TV show
is that overrated?
I've never really,
okay.
A friends is overrated,
right?
I hated this show when it was on and I can't believe that it's considered good
enough to be syndicated nationally and aired every day.
I think this show mostly appeal to women as,
I don't know,
a single guy that was waiting on the edge of their couches for the new episode.
Yeah.
That's one of those chicks shows.
There's no reason.
And um,
I'm sure David Schwimmer isn't really like that in real life,
but,
uh,
I just knew every time they would do a montage of,
of the friends,
you know,
live their little episodes.
He always had to be getting really excited and jumping up and down like a chick
doing like a false settle,
you know,
lean on when chicks like something's going to be exciting and they jump up and
down and clap their hands.
I'm,
or maybe at least TV chicks,
he would always be doing that.
Ooh.
And it just get,
just made as a guy if you just wanted to fucking,
he just want to,
you know,
you just want something bad to happen to them.
That's what I was always waiting for.
I just want to see the episode where Ross got the shit kicked out of him.
You know,
I remember a long time go on and watch the Brady Bunch and uh,
you know,
what's his face?
Bobby did something to,
to Greg and somehow Greg had orange hair and he actually looked like he was mad
enough that he was going to beat the shit out of Bobby.
And Bobby was hiding behind Florence Henderson and uh,
you know,
I remember being a little kid really wanting to see Bobby get the shit kicked
out of him.
Like I wanted it.
I really wanted to see it happen and it's probably why,
you know,
30 years later I'm watching the UFC.
I mean that's the storyline that I want.
You don't have to,
I just thought about that was Greg was actually sort of bang in Florence
Henderson right down.
I wonder if Bobby knew Mike Lucan land.
I guess.
Evidently he lives in Utah.
I don't even know why.
I fucking know that.
Um,
alright.
Underrated.
Somebody said Radiohead attends.
Some of you guys,
I don't know about these suggests.
Is Radiohead really underrated?
Critically acclaimed.
Everybody like talking about awesome.
There are,
this band has been around for a very long time.
Is yet to put out an album that would be below three stars on your four star
scale system.
Whenever I try to talk to people about them or even to get a group of people to
go see them play live.
Nobody is interested at all.
And No,
I don't talk about Radiohead all the time.
The media barely ever talks about the band and when they do,
they only talk about OK computer,
the band's third album.
This band deserves a lot more attention and praise from people as they are one
of the best bands ever form.
Um,
I got it.
Okay.
And I know what you saying.
Well this is what you got to look at.
You know,
no matter how good have band is,
it's never going to get the attention of some girl with no panties on or with
their titties hanging out.
I mean,
I dunno,
I'm probably speaking out of turn here because I don't have a vagina,
but it really just seems like women realize this and they just showing their
fucking ass and things
like,
even like girls who will like respectable.
It's like,
no,
I'm not doing this.
I'm not doing booty videos and blah blah blah blah.
And then they finally get on like a sitcom or something and the first Red Day
do,
do you know what I'm saying?
They got the little coochie cutters,
the fucking who has hanging out,
you know,
they got two fingers,
the index and middle finger over both nipples with their mouth half open.
Like,
oh there's somebody want their cock sock.
They always do like that,
that photo shoot,
you know,
laying down completely naked and everything.
Somehow you don't quite see their ass crack and there's no nipple,
but you basically,
you basically see their entire body except for the ass crack and some nipples.
Other than that,
you've seen every piece of flesh that's on them.
And uh,
you know,
they always do that.
I Dunno.
That's what I don't understand.
Women always bitching about that type of shit.
Talking about,
Oh,
you're treating this like sex objects.
It's like fuck you every,
every time your career is in trouble.
You put on a pair of fuck me pumps and you bend over a couch and then they go
the new sizzling pictures of fucking
who's one of these girls I saw do well,
get back to friends,
Jennifer Aniston and,
but she did that.
And unrolling stone,
you know,
one of the highest selling things ever.
I think women should embrace being treated as sex objects.
You know what,
what do,
what do you want to be?
We're not,
what are you want to be known for being like a meteorologist.
I know sometimes I should just stop talking cause that just keep going and then
just get dumber and dumber.
I think that even answer that question.
All right.
Uh,
we got,
we got a couple of other here,
couple others here.
This guy said last week you mentioned voting for Ron Paul because of the Federal
Reserve.
Um,
John,
it's the wrong one.
Okay.
Bill,
here's a question.
Do you have a sketch comedy show in the works also,
now that Randy coture is out and then went on to say his name.
What are your thoughts on Brock Lesnar versus Fidor door and Mac?
I like I Linko.
Who Do you think will win?
Uh,
I have no fucking idea.
I gotta be honest with you.
I have no idea.
I just know Brock Lesnar was one of the biggest human beings I've ever seen.
His one of his pecs,
you know,
it's,
it's
like this,
the Pec muscle is the thickness of my entire torso and the size,
like from my neck down to my waist.
So I don't know.
Doesn't he have like a fucking tattoo right between his pecs?
It's like a dagger.
It's either a dagger.
I,
one of those Ben Franklin quill pens.
I don't know where this,
I have no idea.
I don't know who the fuck is going to win it,
to be honest with you.
I've been doing a lot of standup and those fights always come on Saturday
nights.
I ordered the package,
so now my cable bills like fucking 200 bucks a month.
And,
uh,
you know what I hate?
I hate whenever you're the guy hosting the fight,
right?
And you're like,
again,
I know I won't invite six other guys to come over.
Everybody tosses me fucking whatever,
10,
15 bucks.
And then,
you know,
the fight costs me,
10,
15,
and whatever.
What happens?
Everybody throws,
you crumpled up twenties the end of the night,
you stuff it in your pocket and you go out and you spend it on gumballs and
fucking raisins and you know,
toilet paper and then the bill comes along and it's like,
you never had that money.
I don't know why.
Why can't you just be thankful during the week of Thanksgiving that you got some
fleet toilets,
April,
blah.
That is the worst fucking shirt I've ever seen.
Picture a lime Green Charlie Brown shirt except this and did the zig zag line is
just straight.
And for some weird reason,
you're wearing it with intelligence,
Colo style.
And for some reason you're wearing black slacks with it.
And then you ran across the parking lot and sort of a run walk on the balls of
your feet.
Like how Walter Payton use the F,
maybe he's trying to avoid major injury just like him.
Anyways,
let me wrap it up.
This fucking podcast cause I got some Chia tell you have to go do when I go back
into the building and old man.
Um,
all right.
Oh,
what are we gonna do?
let's hype.
But type what I got coming.
Oh,
first of all,
you know what I forgot to do with fucking thing.
I've got to do at the top of this podcast.
I wanted to thank Joe Perry from Aerosmith for calling in,
uh,
uninformed.
There's the radio show I do with Joe to Rosa.
We had a great time interviewing him and he was obviously our biggest and
coolest guests we've ever had.
Totally down to earth.
And uh,
you know,
I dunno,
it's pretty fucking awesome to get to interview somebody who you've been
listening to for the last 30 years,
you know?
So that's what I'm thankful for this week at Thanksgiving and a,
I would also be thankful if people come up to my show.
Caroline's the first weekend in December.
Let's see,
seventh,
sixth,
fifth,
fourth,
December 4th through the seventh.
I'll be a Caroline's comedy club on Broadway.
The last stop on the uninformed tour with me and Joe to Rosa with special
guests,
Harris Stanton who will be hosting.
And uh,
and that's it.
Happy Thanksgiving to everybody.
Thank you for sending in the questions.
Oh,
and if you guys could do me a favor,
if you can go to my website,
if you're not on it right now,
just go to [inaudible] dot com if you scroll down on the right hand side,
you can actually see where you can sign up for my email list just because a lot
of times they send out bulletins about being in Seattle on my space and they
ended up going to people who live in Albuquerque.
If you,
if you're on my website,
you literally just sign up on the,
uh,
the city that's nearest you.
So that way you don't have to get a fucking email from me every two weeks.
I just don't want to be spamming people or any of that shit.
So if you sign up on my website,
you'll only get bulletins from me when I'm playing in your area or if I'm going
to be on TV.
Basically if it's something that you can either watch here or go to,
it's the only time you'll get emails.
All right.
So that is it.
Thank you for listening to the podcast.
I apologize the last couple of weeks of feeling like he thinks it's been a
little bit lame because I've been,
uh,
I've been really busy trying to do,
do some shit out here and um,
and that's it.
So what have I got next weekend?
Next week is going to be allowed to do a Sunday night.
Next week there will be a Sunday night podcast and I'll,
I'll be better rested for it.
All right.
But I appreciate you guys sending them the questions and I'll just keep saying
the same thing over and over again for another 18 minutes if I don't hang up.
All right,
so you guys all have a good Thanksgiving and uh,
you know,
and just try to remember what you have to be thankful for.
All right.
I'll try it
the next week.
You can't see what care
to the patients.
Sarah?
Uh,
uh,
uh.
Oh Wow.